dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jean I say here
whenever we take an image with our
camera and look at it after an event we
often feel that many of them are close
to perfect if only it was less blurry or
the focus distance was a bit further
away but the magic moment is now gone
and there is nothing to do other than
cursing at the blurry footage that we
are left with when showing it to our
friends however if we have access to
light fields we can change some camera
parameters after the photo was taken
this includes changing the focal
distance or even slightly adjusting the
viewpoint of the camera how cool is that
this can be accomplished by a
light-filled camera which is also
referred to as a plan optic camera this
tries to record not only light
intensities but the direction of
incoming light as well earlier this was
typically achieved by using an array of
cameras that's both expensive and
cumbersome and here comes the problem
with using only one light field camera
because of the increased amount of data
that they have to record current light
field cameras are only able to take
three frames per second that's hardly
satisfying if we wish to do this sort of
post editing for videos this work offers
a novel technique to remedy this
situation by attaching a standard camera
to this light field camera the goal is
that the standard camera has 30 so tons
of frames per second but with little
additional information and the light
field camera which has only a few frames
per second but with a ton of additional
information if we stitch all this
information together in a smart way
maybe it is a possibility to get full
light field editing for videos earlier
we have talked about interpolation
techniques that can fill some of the
missing frames in videos this way we can
fill in maybe every other frame in a
footage or we can be a bit more generous
than that however if we are shown three
frames per second and we have to create
a smooth video by filling the blanks
would almost be like asking an algorithm
to create a movie from the comic book
this would be awesome but we're not
there yet
too much information is missing this
stitching process works with a bit more
information
than this and the key idea is to use two
convolutional neural networks to fill in
the blanks one is used to predict flows
which describe the movements and
rotations of the objects in the scene
and one to predict the final appearance
of the objects basically one for how
they move and one for how they look and
the results are just absolutely
incredible it is also bleeding fast and
takes less than a tenth of a second to
create one of these new views here you
can see how the final program is able to
change the focal distance of any of the
frames in our video or we can even click
on something in the image to get it in
focus and all this is done after the
video has been taken the source code of
this project is also available with some
more improvements this could be
tremendously useful in the film industry
because the directors could adjust their
scenes after the shooting and not just
sigh over the inaccuracies and missed
opportunities and this is just one of
the many possible other applications
absolutely amazing if you have enjoyed
this episode don't forget to subscribe
to two minute papers and also make sure
to click the bell icon to never miss an
episode thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]